you
welcome to native Lincoln's course on
using the IPA to help you with
pronunciation in a ford language or any
language you're learning when we talk
about vowels in the context of IPA or
phonetics we don't tend to say things
like the letter A or the letter U or the
vowel U even instead we break down
vowels by their features and features
are kind of like the component parts of
vowels each vowel has multiple features
the first of these features is vowel
height if you want to think about it
anatomically you can distinguish
different vowel Heights by considering
the position of your jaw when you make a
certain vowel sound for instance when I
make the open sound all my jaw is in a
different position than it is when I say
the closed vowel e so my jaw opens up
between E and all you can also relate
hype to how close your tongue is to the
roof of your mouth it's closer when you
say the sound e than it is when you say
all we can distinguish open mid and
closed vowels backness is the other
feature we should distinguish at this
point backness involves instead what we
can think of as how far forward and how
far back our tongue is in our mouth
that's the anatomical way of thinking
about it so if you again say the vowel e
your tongue is fairly far forward in
your mouth but if you say all you pull
it back so that's the feature backness
we can distinguish three levels of
backness the first one is going to be
back the second one is central and the
third is front
using those two features backness and
height we can lay vowels out on the
table with the x axis being backness and
the y axis being height this will allow
you to lay out all of your basic vowels
on a chart and to be able to pronounce
them in relation to each other let's
take a look at one of those charts and
how pronounce the sounds for you e eh eh
eh ah ah ah oh oh ah ah